después de europa en ya eeuu allí
decenas de millones de personas se ven
afectadas por olas de calor extremos una
de las consecuencias más dramáticas por
las altas temperaturas y la sequía es el
out fire un incendio que arde en
california amenazando con arrasar el
emblemático parque yosemite y sus
huellas gigantes el sábado el fuego se
expandió por unas 4.800 hectáreas y más
de 6000 personas fueron evacuadas el
incendio está siendo combatido por más
de 500 bomberos que luchan por
controlarlo y lo describen como extremo
es realmente desgarrador porque ha sido
año tras año y solo pensar en todo el
estado de california y en todas sus
partes afectadas hubo tantos incendios
en el resto del país el calor sofocante
se dejó sentir en la capital washington
donde la temperatura se acercó a los 38
grados
nueva york- no se salvó con un mercurio
que marcó los 35 grados mientras que el
calor podría alcanzar los 43 grados en
zonas del sur
el noreste según el servicio
meteorológico estadounidense
paralizado en el congreso
dubai de nintento el 20 de julio revivir
sus promesas climáticas como presidente
tengo la responsabilidad de actuar con
urgencia y determinación cuando nuestra
nación se enfrenta a un peligro claro y
de eso se trata con el cambio climático
en junio de 2000 venció en una cúpula de
calor y usualmente intensa causó
estragos en toda la costa oeste de eeuu
y canadá matando a más de 500 personas y
provocando incendios forestales masivos
con temperaturas cercanas a los 50
grados